hello there my name is Karen Borden I'm
with la talk radio still courage i'm
here at the 6th annual san diego indie
vest and i'm here with mr. Peter Bester
waka who is one of the cofounders of
recca movie calm and tell us what is
recognized calm and what inspired him
yes a wrecker movie is actually
something that we started after having
done starring so starak was actually the
first full feature length movie with
della good college special effects that
was actually crowdsource before you know
people start talking about crowdsourcing
it was done by some loot or Sonnen and
team of water and solar who directed it
and then basically they started this
already way back in 98 like early days
of the internet and all of that and they
they started making a star trek parody
called starring and then because they
didn't know that much about filmmaking
they started asking people online that
ok could you help us with you know
making some space ship designs I could
you help us with the script and this and
that and then basically they invited
hundreds of people around the world to
work on the movie took them seven years
and then in 2005 we you know had you
know Star Trek in the beginning which
movie and then they were like okay now
we have this move in finish it's a
science fiction sci fi movie what do we
do with this and then they just decided
okay let's you know what planet are
intended security for free and because
they had worked with the community they
immediately got like a million downloads
per million and right now we're at nine
million downloads and what was very very
interesting with this whole thing is
that after it was given away for free
dating the deal with universal for a
commercial DVD de Sala TV rights to
Japan Italy
finland all over the planet and the most
important wall so tons of t-shirts have
made a few hundred k so it was pretty
good for a free movie where this record
movie go here yeah so recommen after
historic experience and having you know
made a movie working together with
people all over the planet thought okay
this isn't something that we should
enable for other people as well so why
don't we take the store experience and
car like you know put it in a box or or
create a service around this so we
actually build rekha movie i started
this services community for filmmakers
anybody interested in making movies and
right now it's actually possible for
anybody to start their own production
invite their friends or anybody
interested in you know i can pick out
and make reason we actually now have
over 300 movies like movies under
production we have people from 140
countries the biggest production is
actually a movie by timo and Somaly that
you know go on after star report virus
by that has 1500 people around the
planet working on it and it's it's a
movie about not cisco into the moon I
1945 and 2018 coming back so it's a
comedy but anyways room so right now we
were enabling the same kind of
capability for well that we had when Wes
toric was made